Alice Krige might be playing the Witch in
Gretel & Hansel, but the horror-tinged reimagining
of the classic fairy tale isn't the first
time that the veteran actress has played an
iconic baddie.
In 1996, Krige appeared in Star Trek: First
Contact as the villainous Borg Queen, a role
she reprised in Star Trek: Voyager and a couple
of spin-off projects.
With the Borg playing a significant role in
Jean-Luc Picard's latest adventures in the
CBS All Access series Star Trek: Picard, we
thought it'd be interesting to ask Krige about
her time as the former Starfleet captain's
arch-nemesis.
While talking with Looper about her role in
Gretel & Hansel, Krige shared her thoughts
on what it takes to bring a memorable villain
to life, saying,
"I'm interested in what it is to be human
and to be alive.
Your job as an actor is to try to bring the
humanness, the frailty, the bit that we all
recognize."
However, when it came to playing Star Trek's
Borg Queen, finding the humanity in the character
presented some difficulties, since, as Krige
explained,
"I don't think she is human.
No one has told me this; this is what I have
come to myself, [but] I think she was an entity
that happened at the moment of creation.
And she's always been that and she always
will be, and it is entirely abnormal."
"Human.
We used to be exactly like them.
Flawed, weak, organic."
In addition, when it comes to larger-than-life
roles like the Borg Queen or Gretel & Hansel's
Witch, Krige noted that it can make the task
of grounding those characters particularly
challenging, saying,
"You are allowed to live life through those
characters as large as it is possible to write
it [...] They're archetypes.
Somehow they crystallize or distill the human
condition [...] It's about catharsis, about
the insoluble problem of being human."
On the other hand, villainous parts do provide
Krige with a sense of freedom.
As the actress revealed to Looper,
"With other roles, you need to try and be
just like someone you'd meet in the street.
You're not going to meet [the Witch or the
Borg Queen] in the street.
So every now and then, to be given the chance
to live in the magic forest is wonderful because
it crystallizes on certain levels what we
all face as human beings in a very, very bold,
in-your-face kind of way."
But even though Krige seems to have a good
handle on her dark characters, playing villains
still can take a severe mental toll.
As an actress, Krige has to live inside her
characters' heads for weeks, or sometimes
even months.
When she's playing characters like the Witch
and the Borg Queen, that's not necessarily
a nice place to be.
In fact, Krige almost didn't accept the role
of the Witch in Gretel & Hansel because she
was wary of spending so much time in the dark.
In 2006, Krige played a cult leader named
Christabella in Silent Hill, and it left quite
a mark on her psyche.
Speaking of her experience on Silent Hill,
Krige said,
"I didn't anticipate with Christabella how
dark she would be.
You take something on, and you can't do half-measures.
You have to go inside that space, right?
And the last few weeks it was just Christabella
mad and burning people.
It was a dark space to go to."
"That is where the darkness lies.
The demon is in the bowels of this building.
It hides behind the face of an innocent."
Thankfully for her own well-being, the actress
has since emerged from that dark space.
Thanks to Gretel & Hansel director Osgood
Perkins' gentle touch, Krige felt totally
comfortable inhabiting her latest villainous
role.
Speaking about Perkins' approach, Krige said,
"I knew that he would come to the Witch without
judgment, and that he would illuminate who
she was and what she became with understanding
and compassion.
Osgood was always looking at her point of
view, with her pain, with her compulsion,
her grief, her shame, her exhaustion."
Ultimately, that human perspective is what
helped separate the Witch from the Borg Queen
in Krige's mind.
As the actress noted,
"By the end [of Gretel & Hansel] you had a
human being who didn't start off in this place,
but who wound up in this place.
Sometimes we make decisions all alone, and
we live with them for the rest of our lives.
And that's what happened to the Witch."
That's a far cry from Krige's take on the
non-human Borg Queen.
Looking back on her iconic Star Trek role,
Krige said,
"I wouldn't like to spend my life inside the
Borg Queen, but it was a great adventure to
live inside her."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.